Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
attack on titan season 4 episode 6 video i got
a lot of requests to do attack on titan videos for
the final season because this is the end they're
only going to be 16 episodes total so be sure to
subscribe to get everything there were so many
wtf moments and a lot of easter eggs and they're
paying off a lot of long-running plots explaining
a lot of what's really been going on this whole
time like a lot of the characters have been misled
about what they think is going on when really the
story has been completely different this whole
time we'll do a giveaway for crunchyroll premium
memberships all you have to do to enter is just be
a subscriber and leave your favorite moment from
the episode on the video careful for spoilers
if you have not seen the episode i'm just gonna
number these as we go along just to stay organized
but Eren our protagonist since the beginning now
is being portrayed as the villain of the series in
a way so to speak he doesn't think of himself as
the villain but he kind of understands what he's
doing he's basically here in marley though to
collect more titan abilities like pokemon gotta
catch em all gotta catch all those titan powers
the other reason why he's doing this if it wasn't
clear from last week's episode they kind of imply
but i don't think they explicitly talked about why
he was doing all this is because he's trying to
start a war in order to end it faster and he's
also trying to marley's military structure it's
hard to talk about his true intentions without
getting into spoilers for stuff we haven't seen
so if you have read the manga ahead of this please
do not post those spoilers in the comments you
learn a lot more about why Eren came to this
decision too they haven't explained too much of
it you kind of assume what he's thinking in his
conversation with reiner in last week's episode
like okay this is the only way to end all this
suffering but it's much more complicated than
that he didn't just turn on a dime and decide
to do all this by himself but at the beginning
of the episode they do this big flashback where
you find out willy's plan to bring the jaegers in
line and keep things from getting out of control
like he himself had his own plan as part of
this knowing that he was going to his death
so it wasn't like Eren's actions were a complete
surprise he knew that something was going to
happen and they were trying to spin that to
their advantage he just didn't account for how
crazy things were going to get you also see that
they agonize over the inevitable collateral damage
in a way that Eren doesn't at least not verbally
you kind of register it on his face when he's
talking to mikasa later like you can see that
he understands the weight of what he's done
there's no coming back from this but willy tyber
and magath just talk it out a little bit more
verbalizing some of their regrets about all this
like yes it is terrible that all the people in the
internment camp the eldians will die they are
our people remember willy tyber is an Eldian
himself even though in previous episodes when he
was talking to all those assembled nations he was
talking about the Eldians as if they were devils
but the whole idea with this and they sort of
hammered this home with a lot of the other story
lines is that everyone in this conflict will have
blood on their hands no one is free from blame in
the greater conflict between marley and Paradis
if you're a big rick and morty fan they did
a version of that storyline during rick and
morty season 3 on the citadel of ricks where you
have that line same old same old morty's killing
mortys where the police morty winds up killing a
whole bunch of other mortys it's a war it's ugly
that's just the way it goes then they jump forward
in time to the very end of episode 5 in that same
moment as willy's being killed by Eren who then
begins to fight the warhammer titan revealed to
be willy's younger sister previously they'd kept
the inheritor of the warhammer titan a secret
within their family just to prevent assassination
attempts like in an earlier episode he's talking
to macgath and says i bet you wonder where
the warhammer titan is yes it's definitely
somewhere in this house one of us definitely
has it but he wouldn't reveal who it was
the crowd scrambles in the chaos but i love the
way that the assembled marleyan leadership the
military leaders there just sit there just staring
even one of them just knows that he's about to
die and just takes it calmly like yep this is
definitely going to happen i am definitely going
to get eaten by this titan here most of the marley
and warrior candidates themselves are either
killed or scattered but you still have falco
gabi and a couple others that have survived
as willy's sister activates the warhammer titan
you notice how the rest of the marley military in
the area just sort of chill out a little bit like
oh finally we're saved the warhammer titan is here
they will destroy this new titan will be able to
take the powers of the founding titan because all
the stories they've been told about the warhammer
titan going back to the great titan war 100 years
ago make it seem like the warhammer titan is
invincible the tyber's are invincible because
they've never actually seen it in a real battle
before but the problem that a lot of you probably
realized before this is that his sister who's
never actually really used the warhammer titan
is extremely inexperienced she doesn't know how to
wield it to its full abilities and Eren has long
since mastered all of the abilities of the attack
titan as well as more advanced titan abilities
like hardening so even though she's able to get in
some really good blows with the warhammer titans
basic powers she is completely outmatched in
this fight Pieck and marcel are able to escape
that pit that yelena dumped them into when Pieck
reveals that she didn't lose it when she saw her
military comrades from the panzer unit earlier
she was secretly orchestrating a plan to have
them come rescue her because she suspected yelena
this whole time a suspected beardy this whole time
then as they prepare to shift into their titans
Pieck flips out at the revelation that the forces
of Paradis have also infiltrated marley in our
attacking as if Eren's titan weren't enough for
them to deal with they only thought that there
was a titan to deal with they didn't know this was
going to be a full-scale attack and pretty much
all of marley is unprepared for this because it's
largely an inside job like willy tyber was talking
about earlier we get to see the warhammer titans
namesake ability as it fashions a giant warhammer
smashing Eren in the chest then creates a field
of spikes all around him and as Eren is coming
under fire from all over the place it's really
easy to see who's more advanced in situations like
this with their titan abilities just based on how
they react to stuff like this when it gets real
crazy notice how Eren knows to protect his nape
a new titan inheritor wouldn't know to do that but
mcgoth is hoping that the warhammer titan is going
to be able to eat Eren's titan to gain the power
of the founding titan but even though she's able
to lop off his head with a crushing blow from
her hammer Eren advanced titan user survives
no big surprise there and when she asks if he
has any last words he reveals the true extent
of their orchestrated attack on marley calling
mikasa and the others into action the combined
forces of the survey corps attacked the warhammer
with their newly upgraded 3d maneuvering gear and
the thunderspheres technology they developed from
the more advanced 3d gear that the Eldian military
interior police have been creating for the sole
purpose of fighting the survey core they've had
the thunderspheres for a little while now because
they use them against reiner's armor titan a while
ago but the bigger upgrades are integrating
that with the special new 3d maneuvering gear
the thunder spears are basically just extra
hardcore anti-titan weapons for piercing hardened
titan skins like the warhammer titan and the armor
titan possess i love the way that mikasa pauses
mid carnage to tell Eren to come home because he's
been doing this secret marley plan for years at
this point but as he explained to falco in last
week's episode he'd been using him to pass them
messages this whole time so it's not like he's
been completely out of communication with all of
his friends this whole time it's just that they
haven't actually seen him in a long long time
marley does their best to mobilize all remaining
forces in the area everywhere from around even in
the bay all their ships there'll be some special
surprises there in next week's episode no spoilers
if you've read the manga still though they're
taken completely by surprise in the survey corps
members argue about collateral damage too hurting
innocent people the same conversation that willy
tyber was having earlier in the episode before
this big attack happened but you notice that
on both sides some feel like everyone deserves
it that they're hurting like the marley people
deserve everything that's happening to them even
though we're technically killing innocent people
they all deserve what happens to them we need
a devil like Eren right now i love the way
they refer to Eren as a devil like everyone thinks
that the eldians are devils even the other Eldians
it's more that idea that Eren has become the
villain of the story at least for right now
and even though mikasa will follow Eren anywhere
even into death she also tries to get him to
realize what he's done and even though he doesn't
argue with her or try to deny anything that she's
saying that sad look on his face that he gives her
makes it seem like he understands what he's done
but still thinks this is the only way i'll never
be able to undo this or come back from this but
this is the only way then we jump back to gabi
who's just gone completely off the rails with
her desire for revenge she's able to pursue
a few survey corps members including sasha
so she's gonna have blood on her hands pretty
soon too the whole thing that falco was trying
to prevent by beating her in their test to take
her out of the running for inheriting a titan
so that she wouldn't have to go to war on Paradis
she'd be able to have his happy normal life this
whole quest for revenge is going to be a big part
of gabi's character arc going forward with falco
right now she's dead set against the Paradis
Eldian's being devils don't talk to them don't
be friends with them kill them all every chance
you get but they eventually raise the question you
know what about the normal everyday eldians living
on Paradis rodies are they devils too the ones who
never wielded a titan the ones who are just calmly
trying to lead normal lives she's an aldean just
like them and you remember that falco sort of
had this realization on his face when he was
there for Eren and reiner's conversation about how
they're both the same and Eren no longer harbors
any resentment against reiner he doesn't hate
him anymore for his actions as the armored titan
no longer has any real desire to destroy him in
reiner is also regretting a lot of the things that
he did as the armor tightened as well even though
things got really crazy at the end of last week's
episode when Eren transformed they effectively put
aside their differences but gabi wasn't there like
falco so she hasn't come to that realization you
notice that the warhammer titan is still using
pretty rudimentary weapons against mikasa who's
making pretty quick work of it with her new 3d
gear and the thunder spears and levi was already
amazing with the 3d gear before they got their big
upgrades so he wrecks in this episode but he's
even better in next week's episode and Eren is
able to figure out the powers of the warhammer
titan on the fly like he immediately senses what's
really going on wait a minute the reason why it
was created from the ground up is because the
person is not inside the titan it's being remote
piloted so he forms his new attack titan body and
digs the control pod which is a giant crystal just
like annie's crystal out of the ground but when
he tries to eat the pod right before he can he's
attacked by marcel using his jaw titan who himself
is also relatively inexperienced with his titan
abilities he flips when he's not able to bite
right through Eren's shoulder and the reason he's
not able to do that is because Eren mastered the
hardening ability using it to fortify his attack
titan skin now it's not as strong as the warhammer
titan skin or reiner's armor titan plating but
it's still way stronger than it would normally be
the end on the cliffhanger there and if you have
read the manga please don't post spoilers for what
happens next but you are all in for something
really special next week one of the really cool
things that you see them pay off in this episode
and obviously continue forward in next week's
episode is really advanced in creative use of
titan powers so when the series first started
it was just really cool that Eren could turn into
a titan he could punch things really hard but then
through the course of the series you learn about
the advanced titan abilities about the many many
different abilities that they all possess some of
them are unique some of them have the same powers
for instance the attack titan's ability to inherit
memories from future inheritors of the titan
unlike the other versions of the titans which can
only inherit the memories of previous wielders but
we're in the middle of this fight here where you
have two really inexperienced titans the warhammer
titan and the jaw titan going up against Eren
who's mastered all of the powers of the attack
titan which makes him formidable enough by itself
but on top of that he's also been able to use some
of the powers of the founding titan remember you
can only unlock the true abilities or use the true
abilities of the founding titan if you're a member
of the royal family you have royal blood in you or
if you're touching someone with royal blood we'll
get into that with some of the future episodes
with historia because she has royal blood in her
and zeke because he also has royal blood in him
also we didn't see zeke at all in this episode but
you know he's in a teaser for next week's episode
so he'll be back and they'll explain more of his
role in this giant attack here and reiner was
absent in this week's episode last seen diving to
protect falco from Eren's transformation so he'll
also be back in next week's episode along with
falco but it's only gonna get crazier and crazier
i'm loving season four so far i feel like this is
going to be a masterpiece of a season i'm really
hopeful that they're able to end this really well
even though there's only 16 episodes which is kind
of a bummer you would hope that they would do like
20 plus episodes because there's so much more plot
for them to get through we're not even close to
catching up with the manga right now and the manga
is supposed to be ending in april if you didn't
see the announcements so depending on whether or
not they take any breaks between episodes in
the future we might wind up getting the very
last episode in the very last issue of the manga
around the same time which would help prevent
some spoilers but if you have any big questions
are there any big easter eggs during the episode
that i didn't mention in the video just write them
below in the comments my episode 7 video will post
next week you can click here for my attack on
titan season 4 trailer video where i talk about
some of the other easter eggs that haven't
actually come up yet and you can click here
for those brand new marvel wand division episodes
marvel finally back in 2021 after taking an entire
year off thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you in the next video!